♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
ABORTION HAS NEVER BEEN POPULAR
IN THE STATE OF ALABAMA.
SINCE 1973, WHEN A HANDFUL OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES IMPOSED
THE MOST LEFT-WING ABORTION
REGIME IN THE WORLD BY FIAT,
VOTERS IN ALABAMA HAVE STRONGLY
DISAGREED WITH THE IDEOLOGY OF
ROE V. WADE.
LAST NIGHT AFTER 46 YEARS, THEY
FINALLY ENACTED THEIR VIEWS INTO
LAW.
LAWMAKERS VOTED OVERWHELMINGLY
TO BAN MOST ABORTIONS IN
ALABAMA.
JUST IN ALABAMA, NOWHERE ELSE.
A LAW LIKE THIS WOULD NOT PASS
IN MARYLAND OR NEW JERSEY OR
MASSACHUSETTS.
OR PICK A STATE.
IT APPLIES ONLY IN A STATE WHERE
A STRONG MAJORITY AGREES ON IT
AND REFLECTS THAT COMMUNITY'S
VALUES.
THAT'S CALLED SELF-GOVERNMENT.
IT'S HOW DEMOCRACY IS SUPPOSED
TO WORK.
THE RULING CLASS DOESN'T CARE,
THOUGH.
THEY NO LONGER BELIEVE IN
DEMOCRACY.
SO THE IDEA THAT SOMEWHERE
1,000 MILES FROM BROOKLYN IN
SOME LITTLE TOWN IN ALABAMA,
THERE MIGHT BE A PERSON WHO
DISAGREES WITH THEIR VIEWS ON
ABORTION OR GUN CONTROL OR NAME
A TOPIC.
THAT IDEA DRIVES THEM COMPLETELY
INSANE.
IT EATS AT THEM, IT KEEPS THEM
UP AT NIGHT.
IT MUST BE STOPPED.
CNN IS THE NETWORK FOR PEOPLE
WHO FEEL THIS WAY.
WATCH AS ONE OF THEIR ANCHORS
SOLICITED ADVICE ON HOW TO
SUBVERT THE
WILL OF ALABAMA VOTERS.
>> MY FEELING IS THAT THERE'S
THINGS WE CAN DO
FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT TO PROTEST.
FIRST OF ALL, WE CAN TALK TO THE
MEN IN OUR LIVES AND FIGURE OUT
WHO ARE THE MEN THAT ARE NOT
SUPPORTING THIS.
WE CAN CONTRIBUTE TO PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
WE CAN GO AND SAY THIS ISN'T
WHAT WE WANT.
THIS REALLY, REALLY -- IT'S THE
MOST RESTRICTIVE LAW YET FOR
ABORTION.
WHY NOT DO SOMETHING ON A LARGER
SCALE?
>> DR. PEGGY DREXLER.
>> A PLEASURE.
>> Tucker: CNN THINKS YOU
SHOULD DONATE TO PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
ON "THE VIEW" JOY BEHAR, WHO IS
THE SINGLE UNHAPPIEST PERSON IN
THE WORLD AND AN IMPORTANT
FIGURE IN DEMOCRATIC POLITICS,
WENT EVEN FURTHER THAN THAT AND
CALLED FOR EUGENICS.
SHE DEMANDED ALABAMA'S LAWMAKERS
BE STERILIZED ON THE BASIS OF
THEIR SEX AND SKIN COLOR.
>> CAN WE LOOK AT THE PICTURE OF
THE PANEL OF MEN WHO DID THIS.
WHAT DO THEY HAVE IN COMMON?
THEY ARE ALL MEN.
ALL WHITE GUYS.
>> WEREN'T THERE FOUR WOMEN?
>> NOT HERE.
>> ALL WHITE GUYS.
MAYBE WE SHOULD MAKE IT A LAW
THAT THEY SHOULD ALL BE REQUIRED
TO GET A VASECTOMY.
>> Tucker: JOY BEHAR IS NOT
ELECTED TO ANYTHING, AT LEAST
FOR NOW.
BERNIE SANDERS IS.
HE IS A SITTING U.S. SENATOR.
THIS MORNING HE TWEETED
"ABORTION IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT" WHICH IS ALMOST AS DUMB
AS ANYTHING JOY BEHAR SAID.
ABORTION IS NOT A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT.
IT'S NOT MENTIONED IN THE
CONSTITUTION OR EVEN HINTED AT.
THE LEGAL REASONING BEHIND
ROE VS. WADE IS A JOKE.
EVEN PRO-CHOICE LEGAL SCHOLARS
WILL ADMIT IT IF YOU ASK THEM IN
PRIVATE.
BUT IN PUBLIC, NOBODY CAN SAY
THAT.
NOBODY CAN DEVIATE FROM THE
PARTY LINE.
EVERYONE MUST READ FROM THE
TALKING POINTS PROVIDED BY THE
ABORTION CLINIC LOBBYISTS, AND
SO THEY DO.
>> WHAT THEY DID IN ALABAMA,
GEORGIA, IT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
>> THIS IS AN OUTRAGE, AND IT'S
NOTHING SHORT OF AN ATTACK ON
WOMEN'S BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS AND
CIVIL RIGHTS.
>> TODAY WHEN WE SAW WHAT
HAPPENED IN ALABAMA, LET US ALL
AGREE THAT WOMEN'S HEALTH CARE
IS UNDER ATTACK AND WE WILL NOT
STAND FOR IT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: SO THIS IS THE
MODERN DEMOCRATIC ORTHODOXY.
IF YOU LOVE WOMEN, YOU WILL
ENCOURAGE THEM TO KILL THEIR OWN
OFFSPRING.
IF YOU ACKNOWLEDGE CHILDREN ARE
SACRED AND BEING A PARENT IS
HONORABLE AND NECESSARY AND
MAYBE EVEN MORE MEANINGFUL THAN
A TRIP TO IBIZA THIS SUMMER,
THEN YOU ARE AN OPPRESSOR.
YOU HATE WOMEN.
IN CASE YOU HAVEN'T NOTICED,
IT'S A MOST PERFECT VERSION OF
COMMON SENSE AND OF NATURE
ITSELF.
IT'S GROTESQUE.
WHAT'S THE THINKING BEHIND IT?
WE WILL LET ACTRESS ALYSSA
MILANO EXPLAIN IT.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS A
HUMAN ON THE PLANET THAT IS NOT
PRO-LIFE.
NOBODY WANTS TO GET AN ABORTION.
NOBODY.
WE ARE ALL PRO-LIFE.
BUT THERE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
WE CANNOT AVOID.
THERE IS THE MOTHER'S HEALTH.
THERE IS JUST NOT BEING READY,
YOU KNOW, AND WHAT THAT MEANS
FINANCIALLY AND FOR SOMEONE'S
DESTINY.
THIS IS AN ECONOMIC ISSUE.
>> Tucker: OH, IT'S AN
ECONOMIC ISSUE.
THANKS FOR THE HONESTY, ALYSSA.
WITHOUT ROE VERSUS WADE, WOMEN
MIGHT UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO BE MOTHERS RATHER THAN
JUST DUTIFUL WORKER BEES TOILING
FOR A COMPANY THAT DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT THEM.
THEY MAY START TO UNDERSTAND
THEY CAN PUT THEIR FAMILIES
FIRST IF THEY WANTED BEFORE THE
INTEREST OF SHAREHOLDERS.
YOU CAN'T HAVE THAT.
IT MIGHT HURT MARKETS.
OUR CORPORATE CASE MAKERS PUSH
THE LIE THAT ABORTION IS
LIBERATION.
ONLY IN FARAWAY REMOTE PLACES
LIKE ALABAMA DO PEOPLE MISS THAT
MESSAGE AND CONTINUE TO BELIEVE
THAT CHILDREN ARE MORE IMPORTANT
THAN MARKET CAPS AND STOCK
PRICES.
BUT FOR EVERYONE ELSE, THE
PROPAGANDA IS WORKING AS
INTENDED.
ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT BY THE
CDC, AMERICA'S FERTILITY RATE IS
THE LOWEST IT'S EVER BEEN IN THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT THAT AMERICANS DON'T
WANT TO HAVE CHILDREN.
THEY DO.
ACCORDING TO GALLUP, AMERICANS
WANT JUST AS MANY KIDS AS THEY
WANTED 20 YEARS AGO.
IT SHOWS THAT THEY CAN'T AFFORD
THEM ANYMORE.
OUR LEADERS TELL US THAT'S FINE,
TOTALLY OKAY.
IT'S NORMAL.
YOU DON'T NEED CHILDREN.
HERE IS A NEW iPHONE.
WE'LL PAY FOR YOUR ABORTION.
WORK HARDER.
STOP COMPLAINING.